well we always hear how actors should
market themselves what about a DP I
noticed you had some photos of yourself
with a camera which I thought was
actually really cool like yeah I did
they really learn about that tool I
started seeing other people do it and
the people that I saw doing it I didn't
really think we're that great I wasn't
impressed with their work so I was like
wow those people are getting work from
having pictures of themselves as a
camera maybe I should do that too in
addition to having a good real I still
think the good Rios what gets me must do
my work people looking at pictures of me
with a camera maybe that is cool from
afar but to really understand what I can
do just so I can show my real why don't
have to say a word me just show my real
and so what would you advise other
filmmakers having their reals what type
of you said I would just save for
cinematographers that's the challenging
things night shoots stuff in the rain or
in weather of any kind action stuff
where you're moving the camera and crazy
ways like with the jib or steady cam or
if you're in a helicopter I've tried to
collect those kind of things and I'll
take a gig sometimes if I don't have
something because of that like it like
okay I took this commercial was a good
Japanese real estate commercial it's
like the furthest from my normal gig
right but they were gonna let me use a
techno crane so I was like sure
absolutely i did that commercial and I
went to Chicago in New York and we I got
to use a techno crane I understood what
it was all about and I learned how to do
it of course they asked me if I'd ever
used it before I took like got interview
for the job was like yeah of course I
just still have the footage yet they're
still editing it you know you have to
kind of play that game to a little bit
you